[Music]
hello party people welcome to
honest trailer commentaries the show
where we talk about the other shows
in this case the mandalorian i'm joined
by a fab four
danielle jo lon hello
uh you're my you're my bad bunch uh my
my new republic squad so we're gonna
talk about uh um
mando today season two we already did
season one
and uh i'll give it a one word review of
season two
it's good i liked it what what say you
uh i did not like the very end i liked
everything until the last
uh seven last jedi nine minutes yeah the
last jedi
i don't i i know that's a divisive like
a lot of people that was like all
they've ever wanted from star wars and
it made all of their dreams come true
uh that was the moment to me where it
felt like too much i really
like the balance of new adventure
episodic week-to-week star wars
adventures
and then like little flavors sprinklings
of references to other things around the
universe
i think they're really doing a good job
with that balance and then i think
luke teetered it over the edge to me
okay does one luke spoil uh a series for
uh
for you two guys i didn't say it spoiled
series i just didn't like that moment i
liked everything else
alan hated it danielle what do you think
um i really liked it just like with the
first season it's you know i like the
star wars i'm not
um real big on deep deep star wars lore
and so for me it still kept me really
engaged
um and even though you know we do make
fun of like oh it's a bunch of backdoor
pilots it works out perfectly just
because of the way that they had already
set it up in season one
um so none of that bothered me i really
really enjoyed season two uh looking
forward to all the stuff that comes up
next
yeah go ahead joe oh i was yeah i
thought i thought stakes went up nicely
and
i'm sure we've got multiple
opportunities to get into it in
when we watch the sauna trailer but
really yeah the only the only times it
felt clumsy at all was when it was um
was when it was like setting up a new
show
but small complaint i
you know uh gamoreans wrestled in the
first episode
uh they had gamorean bloodsport that's
fun
uh yeah so i i i can't complain about a
show that gave me comorian's
uh dim mocking each other with vibro
axes can't complain about it gomorian
dimock
that old chestnut um there were there
were two moments where i thought it
overstepped
uh uh into like just overt
fan service and i thought luke was one
of them and i thought just the
the name drop of uh thrawn kind of
rubbed me the wrong way i thought that
you could totally if that was the first
time
uh you saw ahsoka or um really a lot of
the guest stars you would
that's fine that's fine a fine
introduction to them but to just drop
thrawn like it meant something to a
newcomer like no
no and even that you know you could have
just said
where is he and then youtube would have
spent the next two years going who's he
and like freaking out like they could
have done the mystery there yeah that
was one of the
just weird moments where the script
becomes
uh not organic things people would say
but they need to set up a thing
yeah yeah where is grand admiral thrawn
fan favorite character from the eu and
who will play him
like right it was yeah i mean right it
was that it's that they didn't want the
discussion to be who is
he they wanted it to be what it is right
now which is exactly this like
who's going to play thrawn and how are
they going to integrate him and
um yeah i i agree it's a little it's a
little clumsy with that stuff but none
of it really bothered me i was really
into the show and
i loved the like the robert rodriguez
episode where it's like they're on the
planet and baby yoda
who i'm still gonna call baby yoda he's
communing with
mystery jedi somewhere out there and
it's like boba fett and they're taking
on all these stormtroopers and like
that to me is the essence of what this
show can be and it was so much fun
and it like it like ties into the lore
you get to see boba fett people but it's
doing its own thing and it felt like an
original um like to me that's that's
like
perfect peak mandalorian like that's
what i want for the show and it largely
delivered on that in season two
yeah um gosh i mean it's a long trailer
why don't we just dive right into it
because i know we'll all have a lot to
say
uh every every 30 seconds so let's play
the honest trailer for the mandalorian
and as i forgot to mention if we recall
if we remember we'll show some deleted
scenes afterwards
so let's start with this one
fresh from disney's content minds in
outer burbankia
come season two of a show that's either
the greatest thing we've ever seen
or live action star wars has lowered our
expectations so much
basic confidence feels um
i can already see us getting crap for
the for the moments we chose and for not
including any of the last jedi in the
moments that ruined star wars
um but you know you can only pick four
and i think you could make a case for uh
you know the
maybe the blue milk if that's not to
your taste as like a top ten
maybe but i don't know i think that no
nothing from the last jedi for me tops
smoke in a jar sand it gets everywhere
jar jar
jar jarring out and uh rey and kylo
making out
oh you're gonna if we had preloads
if you hadn't included jar of snokes i
like might have quit in protest like
that's that's number one
with a bullet there was there was
someone uh
in the comments who was like i can't
believe you didn't include
luke drinking green milk which prompted
me to wonder
really wonder what color should the milk
have been
for you to be happy like what what
strangely colored milk is like core star
that happens like early in the first
ever star wars movie like how could you
possibly object to that
that's more fundamental to star wars
than like lightsabers i don't know
that's not the best the teeth is the
problem
oh it's the teeth where do you think the
milk comes from baby
[Laughter]
problematic teeth yeah it's something
that we just all shut out like i don't
think about uh you know putting a
spike through a cow's brain when i eat a
burger like i don't want to know where
my milk comes from
um you may as well be sucking on a teat
if you're drinking milk it's all tea
oriented at the beginning star wars it's
all teat oriented
oh sorry that's
[Music]
live action star wars has lowered our
expectations so much
basic confidence feels like seeing the
face of god
it's glorious the mandalorian
season two suit up for more mandalorian
the show that combined the world of star
wars the feel of old samurai films
and the emotional core of reddit's r
slash all community
in a winning mix that keeps things
simple and doesn't overstay its welcome
so you can be sure to sit they'll launch
enough spin-offs to kill the magic for
good next year
you know there's a reason we don't eat
birthday cake every day disney keep
feeding us this yes
i think that um the spin-offs thing it's
a
it's a fine point that we were trying to
make which is that i don't think that
the spin-offs killed
this season but now i think next season
they're gonna kill it now i think
they're really gonna uh uh choke us with
with this kind of star wars content like
i don't think this can support
three or four if you include obi-wan and
maybe more
uh like shows in a similar vein in this
in the same universe kind of dealing
with the same
uh themes i don't think we can take four
live-action western
rip-offs yeah i mean like i agree with
what you're saying here which is they're
spreading it thin and some of these
shows may suffer as a result
but i actually think this might be good
for the core mandalorian
show that they can like a lot of the
setup stuff is gonna be taken over by
other shows
and season three can focus back on din
and jaron and his adventures and like
like
if all of this had to be contained in
the world of the mandalorian by seasons
four or five
we would be getting this crazy huge show
with all of these threats to follow
like i'm looking forward to season three
to see like can we take this story about
him and get it back to you
i'm assuming he's gonna be because
they're not getting their own spin-off
and that's just my assumption
that bo katan and the like retaking
mandalore is going to become
the core mandalorian story yeah because
they're not getting spin up
yeah like if they were getting their own
spin off i'd be like who knows what he's
up to i mean it's not going to be like
the luke and grogu
daycare saga yes
yeah i feel like maybe like the end of
season three will get like what's
happening with grogu let's check it but
um
yeah yeah like i'm actually like i'm
curious to see if the
the spin-off thing improves the core
show mandalorian or
spreads everything too thin like you're
suggesting uh
anyways let's keep going same thing and
we will reject it unless it's marvel
or animated musicals or pixar movies
about giving up on your dreams
okay fine you win stuff my mouth full of
cake mouse daddy
rejoin the mandalorian the galaxy's most
dangerous never nude
but this time he'll break his only rule
about giving face
as he quests to deliver this tiny meme
generator over to a jedi
all while bonding ever deeper with baby
yoda over their shared love
of murder
all right pause are we gonna have frog's
eggs discourse
or not we can choose to skip it we don't
have to do we have to rehash frog sex
discourse
we'll put it to a vote all who want to
discuss frog's eggs raise your hand
okay we're going to just move on past
that just wow
you don't have to talk about everything
so we're going to just
we're just going to glide on past frog's
eggs
so sure it was just going to be cute and
hilarious
let's let's just go with it let's just
say it's cute and hilarious
let's let's sail right past uh yes okay
it isn't technically baby yoda anymore
kroger
but let's stick with baby yoda grogu
baby yoda
he's the secret love child of yoda and
yattle okay clap them cheeks yoda dude
cat that is are you ready to watch the
great
jobs make some deals with each other
then you'll thrill when mando makes a
deal with this marshall
help me kill it i'll give you the armor
deal and strikes a deal with the tuscan
raiders for help
we've struck a deal but when a deal goes
wrong on the way to finding a jedi
lady the deal is off this wasn't that
part of the deal
he'll try to forge a deal with some
fellow mandalorians they're changing the
terms
of the deal and cut a quick deal with
ming na i owe you from last time
we have a deal before he wraps up that
deal with her and boba fett
yeah danielle i think you pointed this
out it's like that what's that
children's story that this is like
uh i think it's like uh this is the
house that jack built
yeah but just like this is the deal that
makes the grogu that gets the luke in
the house that didn't
like that yeah and interestingly like
that's that was my
issue with rise of skywalker but for
whatever reason i
maybe because it's a tv series and i
just have more time to let it breathe
like i don't mind the
long scavenger hunt um it didn't feel as
like
frenetic and like oh go from a to b to c
to d to e uh
it it worked so good i feel like i'm
more aware of it now because of video
games like it's such a cheap
make the video game longer device like
go get this thing to go get that thing
to get the key to open the chest to get
the scroll that has the spell that you
need to get
like that that's what it kind of feels
like but i don't mind it that's what
these shows are like like well you know
he's on a bunch of fetch quests that's
the show yeah
and like i mean he's a bounty hunter it
kind of lends itself to
go fetch this thing and bring it back i
mean in the 50s and 60s like
every show was basically just this it
was just like fetch quest the series
and it was just like paladin go to this
town stop
them ranchers from stealing from those
other ranchers like
you know it worked for decades why not
now yeah
all right keep going wait that's in
addition to any bargains promises or
propositions he'll make along the way we
can strike a bargain you made me a
promise
and i held up my end i have a
proposition that may interest you
then what's in it for me screw credits
the real currency of star wars is the
pinky swear
remember all the interesting and
original side characters you met last
season
they're back at least for now but
they'll make room for all
new faces and by new i mean really old
like yeah buzz why is boba fett so old
now
i don't think it's so much that he's old
it's that a rancor was digesting not a
rancor
um digesting him for like a long time
and he's got digest face
resting digest face digest face after
you get out of that sarge like pit you
look a little like powder
yeah that could be it um yeah i was just
curious like what
that that makes more sense than uh you
know some type of hyper advanced aging
situation
that that's what you look like when you
crawl out of a sarlacc bit
but he does have did anyone ever ask how
he got out
no i mean that's a sensitive subject
spencer like you know
like that you wouldn't want me to just
be like hey by the way
remember when you were digested for ages
i think it'd be a reasonable question
upon showing up
hey how'd you get out of that pit i fell
into a pig
i think they've kind of teased this
because in the season one premiere
they mentioned that the crate dragon
that they're ki that they're attacking
it's living in a sarlacc pit and it ate
the sarlacc
so perhaps the dragon came and attacked
the sarlacc and that is how
it was like a boba fett turducken like a
dragon a sarlacc
and he like scrambled out while the
thing was being you know
it was its attention was elsewhere it's
like qui-gon jinn
said in the phantom menace there's
always a bigger fish it's
poetry it rhymes it rhymes oh my god
that's amazing i'd like to think that
qui-gon appeared as a force goes to boba
fett while he's being digested like my
friend
now is your moment
there's always a bigger fish boba
keep going like the most popular
characters from the clone wars series
the most popular character from empire
strikes back and the most popular
character from star wars
it's official no one in star wars gets
to die or retire anymore
this season's most meaningful death was
when they killed off a merchandising
opportunity
the tech just isn't there yet for the
faces
so enjoy this action-packed journey it
wasn't even just that it was a weird
playstation two-face it was like
everything around because i mean we we
learned after the fact that like
the actors didn't know who it was gonna
be so no one's
everyone's just saying these general
vague lines so that they can pop in
whatever so the whole it was just so
like the whole show is so like organic
and character driven and tightly written
and then like you just get this weird
scene of
people saying like vague like skyrim
dialogue
selections and it is and then you know
here's a shot of r2
because but that doesn't mean anything
like at no point has the show just been
like here's a shot that's just for the
fans like
it's stuff that we get and appreciate
but like at no point
did um did anyone on the water planet
talk about traps and then like wink at
the camera
uh but like all of a sudden you just
have this like
fan service shot of artu and and grogu
just like
loving on each other and it's just like
none of this means anything to anyone
standing in that room
and it was okay so maybe this is um
this is this is actually taking place
like after the the jedi temple was
purged and this is like yoda doing like
a wand division where like he's created
this false reality where like he's back
and it's like he's only 50 years old and
like he's going on cool adventures
and luke's there and everyone's having a
good time
i don't hate that yeah i like this
better than juan division
because he just can't stand the tragedy
that you know that uh the whole jedi
order got slaughtered under his watch
oh yeah he's just like he pretended to
be a kid and he's like i don't want
responsibility
dad yeah i just what bugs me about the
scene is like it should be
it's the payoff moment of mandalorian
and grogu like we've spent the whole
show
developing this relationship this is
their big emotional goodbye
and then it's overshadowed by like cameo
walk-on from the from the original
movies and it's like no like
that scene should belong to them like i
almost feel like it should have been a
character we don't know yet just so that
the focus doesn't leave
the heart of the show which it totally
does because in that moment you're like
piecing together the timeline and oh
he's going to take him to
jedi academy and his kylo ren going to
kill grogu and like all that stuff
it's distracting yeah silly silly season
all right keep going
oh my collectible
so enjoy this action-packed journey
alongside a hardened killer with a heart
of gold
and a soft baby with a heart of darkness
as favro and filoni deliver the second
best star wars experience
ever made for television but you all
know what's still number one
no nut cloning here comes so glad i got
this no not rebels
i'm talking about the intro to the
droid's cartoon come on
[Music]
i do want to point out that this is a
big moment in
honest trailers history because as long
as i have known you i've known your love
of trouble again
for the droid's cartoon so this is a big
moment
i like to think it was like semi-organic
i mean i i i will say i was at a
complete loss for how to end this script
so uh when in doubt i turned to trouble
again
the love theme from droids
it revealed the way to you and uh i
think that's beautiful
yeah i hope it doesn't uh get us in
trouble um
i i i like to think that uh stuart
coupland has better things to do or
whatever company
uh polices these sort of things
oh well uh it's worth it we're going
down going down with that song all right
keep going daft honk
my buddy my buddy wherever i go
he goes ranger of the new republicans
dawson's geek princess leia agents of
shan
lone wolf with club moth diver
darkness no parents red sox leader
standing by
stormtroopers giving themselves away
this is an all time
right i've been thinking about going
vegetarian that's
never vital to the mandalorians it
cannot cut through purgatory the best
car is ours
unreasonably convenient maps and
blueprints this is a map of tatooine
before the war you got mos eisley most
espa
an upper on this region most pell go
we're here
this entire area is the green zone
squirrel doesn't even have email but
over on this side
problem it's also they never have to
like type in a bunch
to get the the map they need is always
like right there ready to go like
somebody set it up in advance for that
it is great that's too big
if your 98 civic hatchback was a
spaceship
i love that decision to not give mando
like the coolest fighter you've ever
seen
like oh no he doesn't care he drives
like a big
the masked slinger
says here you're from alderaan did you
lose anyone
that's such a dumb question i laughed
out loud like i knew that was going to
be an honest trailer joke the very first
time i watched mando season 2 and he
said that i'm like
do you lose anyone on altar yeah there's
no way you saved anyone
whole planet blew up if we if we can
back up to the title shot i just
holtby outdid himself oh yeah yeah yeah
he did
such a good job uh on the mando
season two stuff i think uh ryan
mentioned we even we
were even like you can just use the last
one the season one
he said no i'm an artist and yes and
knocked these out of the park
he made new graphics by hand um it's
ridiculous
yeah uh he's so insanely telling his
emails
with i am an artist i am an artist
[Laughter]
he's he's better than we deserve he's
he's really uh
uh he give him his props because man he
every single week he creates an entirely
new uh typeface and animation and all
this stuff for
our dumb puns for the dumbest puns we
can think of
i know it's really i feel bad sometimes
i'm doing such stupid jokes and just
making them look
visually beautiful ah well um
thank you guys for watching to this
point uh subscribe if you haven't like
if you haven't hit the bell if you
haven't
um and come back to this channel uh
tomorrow for sju and friday for
the episode five review of wandavision
by roth
and eric um and with that out of the way
let's see
uh what didn't make it into the trailer
i will remember to show the outtakes
this week so show them outtakes
so you can be sure to sit they'll launch
enough spin-offs to kill the magic for
good next year
called it because it was a hit they're
probably about to weigh it down with a
bunch of lower crossovers and spin-offs
ah this is the way why am i not
surprised if
or some ghoulish young luke doll on us
no one in the show got to die this year
i'm gonna kill your pet
where was this energy for quill huh
and the most popular character from star
wars called it
who spent eight episodes wondering why
luke skywalker wasn't in the boba fett
show
starring war machine
dinger and
there is no way that this man smells
good terrible
52s million credit baby
yiddle gogurt careful you don't get
cancelled
dune patrol gina carrickpot
bookem tano i want a girl with a short
skirt and a long lekku
oh no sabers i've got you all in check
do you know who my father is crazy
gideon giancarlo
exposition good bill hunting
boston strong arm the empire runs on
duncan
walkie
i feel like you could say there's a lot
of walking in most film
yeah more walking
it's a lot of shots of him just walking
through these environments like it's
cool i don't mind it but there's a lot
more than ever and luke it from orbit
only way to be sure
and luke sky melting
and playing jedi fall in order on a ps3
better loot next time he's three mercs
and a baby
raising arieota mando and the backdoor
pilots
the sad batch
yes baby yoda eats the frog lady's
unborn children but look at what the
rest of the galaxy calls food
you drink it it stinks by creed
why did this luke seem feel so weird oh
because her scene partner was the
marketing department
got it
there you go yes we unintentionally
entered frog eating discourse
thank god that got caught geez who wants
to be part of that go back out
um so yeah go ahead
should they have just gone ahead and
take cause they're gonna make a luke
show
at some point should they have just
taken the swing and had bucky barnes or
whatever his name is come in and be like
hi it's me luke skywalker
yeah i like i'm a big fan of just recast
and
find some cool actor who's around now
who's roughly the same age
just like throw them in there like i
also thought in rogue one charles dance
would have been a great moth tarkin you
don't need to do peter
well anymore i don't like it yeah like
just recast it with somebody who looks
the part and is cool that we like and
that'll work
yeah i think we're we're five years away
from being five years away from
being able to raise the dead digitally
so
and that's probably for the best um
so we got some questions this is a
pre-tape uh uh we were having some live
difficulties but we did manage to get a
few questions in and wow these are
really long questions i'm just gonna
read them blind i hope they make sense
you ready
all right crossbones6732 writes is this
show really action-packed i mean the
empire's literally no threat they can't
even pretend that's the case when
characters in universe laugh at how easy
it is to kill them
if victory is a foregone conclusion and
i could just skip to the end on the
assumption the good guys win with no
casualties where's the tension
love the series but season three needs
to introduce someone actually
intimidating who scores a win a few
times
so was that was the empire not uh
menacing enough for you i guess is the
question
i i just disagree i mean the empire as a
unit is not what it once was but
certainly maf gideon doesn't seem like
super understaffed he's got a light
cruiser he's got this
these killer terminator droids like
i feel like he's he's a he's enough of a
threat to make the season work
yeah i kind of feel like um you know
he's a step ahead of everyone at all
times and that's what makes him scary
um you know that's what made him scary
when he showed up in season one and
suddenly
like had read the wikipedia entry on all
of them
um and then you know and this even in
this season like even when they were
attacking the cruiser was a step ahead
was a step and really the only thing
that saved him was
melty luke showing up um and if he's in
custody that probably makes him
worse in a way like if he's just sitting
in a new republic
you know ship prison ship somewhere that
probably makes him scarier
and also i guess i just don't i don't
know i for me the series is the fun
of uh then going around to different
places and interacting with other people
i'm not super worried about like
whether or not the empire feels super
intimidating because for me that's just
not like the fun of the series anyway
so i i mean i thought that the
the the point they were trying to make
which was a weird one was like
empire republic it don't matter like
things are always the same out here on
the outer rim
um but just like okay uh i think they
they kind of went
uh a few times i was trying to find my
notes because i started tracking it if
the amount of times that they're like
yeah the new republic's not just as bad
but like it doesn't make a difference
who's in charge
um which was a choice uh
which is yeah which is definitely a
weird thing for star wars of all things
to say
when the point of star wars was it sure
does make a difference who's in charge
no but i think i mean but i to to their
defense i would say i think that's also
this point in history like we're at the
beginning of the new
republic and so there's a lot of like
skepticism i mean these are people
who've lived under
this autocratic regime for decades now
so
like it would it would feel unnatural if
it was just like
things are so much better right away you
know like i feel like they're kind of
organically trying to make it like and
also
laying the groundwork for what we know
will happen which is the first order
swooping in
and taking back over so yeah i don't
know i feel like i feel like that
i it's interesting that they're doing
that it's i think that's
cooler and more thoughtful than the
other thing they could have done which
is yeah i do agree there has to be some
shaky ground
for you know because like favro
not favro jj jj said you know like the
first sort of the idea is like what if
the third reich was hanging out in
central america and all of a sudden like
bam we're back
so there does have to be some shaky like
i don't know like people pissed off
enough because they didn't get their mon
mothma stimulus checks or whatever
um that they could kind of like get
their hooks back in so yeah
and also like danielle said that i don't
i don't think big bad is the point
of this i think no we got to get to
thrawn where's thrawn
that throne the throne throne yeah
all right so next question wayward mind
ass i saw someone say above they don't
know where the mandalorian goes without
grogu if that's true for the show then
the show was a failure from the start
wasn't it
uh uh to to put that in a smaller
package uh can the show succeed without
grogu
what do you think oh
yeah i mean i think for sure it just
depends on do they have a
cool interesting new direction in mind
but i don't think grogu you have to have
that
really i think he'll be back at some
point but i i think we i could
see mando do something else for a season
or two
yeah i don't care so much though i mean
they can make me care
with storytelling but i don't really
care about him retaking
mandalore and it's like oh he touched
the sword first so he's the sword guy
and they gotta
do the sword fight like that's not as
compelling to me as like him
taking care of uh of this little cute
factory
so i'm i'm concerned but i'm sure they
could cook up
you know something even cuter in
in the lab i'm wondering if he goes to
visit grogu
and he walks in on luke panicking
because grogu has a
has a dark luke sees grogo eat a frog
egg
and immediately just tries to capture us
again
jyn just gets his buddy out of there
real quick
i mean i do i'm assuming towards the end
of season three there's going to be some
you got to go grow yeah i don't
yeah i don't think he's out of the show
permanently
i think we're gonna we're gonna have a a
few arcs without him and then he'll be
back
all right final question uh frostbite
talks a lot about how bill burr was one
of the highlights
uh it's more than a typical filler
episode best act and most
interesting ones of the whole show uh um
was bill burr
uh your favorite side character and if
not who was your favorite
uh uh person on the side that popped in
this season
i mean i think number one for me boba
fett it was so cool to see that
character finally get to
be cool and like do action
and not be you know like a cool guy in
armor who disappears and
gets murked right away um but i i did
like
mayfeld a lot and i thought bill burr
really did a nice job with the material
so i don't disagree
i think probably the marshall for me i
want to say sasha banks because i know
everyone's going to expect me to say
sasha banks and yes
sasha was very very cool uh i didn't i
don't remember what her in character
name is doesn't matter because she sasha
banks
uh she did tornado ddt it was awesome
but
it was amazing it changed my life but i
think it was the marshall was probably
my favorite of the sidekick you mean the
kim's convenience dude
timothy yeah sorry i in my head i've
rolled the
uh kim's convenience guy into marshalls
of the new republic um
uh if you haven't watched him
convenience watch it he's great in it
uh and a very sweet follow on twitter
but uh
he's the older x-wing pilot from the
from the new republic
yeah who who was wondering about
alderaan uh right
the guy that's dumb questions about uh
i'm gonna
boba fett probably just i don't know
there was something cool uh
danielle knows that my favorite type of
wrestler is the uh
uh the the dad bod luchador that should
probably retire
you know and like boba fett coming in
and rocking a
you know a blue demon rey mysterio in
their 40s
like um a dad mod frame
with like the hakka skirt kind of thing
he had going on was
was dope like that was super awesome uh
but if not him the spider the ice spider
that was the ice spider yeah i like the
spiders i know they
people have some real spider problems um
and i think i have a normal amount of
spider problem which is like i don't
love them don't love to see one on your
face but like it's not something i think
about very often they made those
fighters terrifying
my god that was a real toothy anus
spider if i've ever seen one yeah
so props to the creature design team
there or uh how dare you to the
creatures
you know that was originally i believe
ralph mcqueary originally did the
concept art for those for empire strikes
back and they just didn't get used
uh and it sat on a shelf for all those
years and so that's why it's so
delightfully designed man that guy could
tooth up an orifice
that's gonna be one of the most fun
parts about making a show like that
is you just get let into in the dusty
old
unused concept art room and someone goes
make a 20-minute western out of
that like that's gotta be such a fun job
ah
someday let's go back to the lab and
start putting some anus spiders together
out of clay
let's see what we come up with uh thank
you guys so much for sticking with us
uh sorry the show wasn't live today we
should be back live next week uh
as we cover another honest trailer um
i wouldn't say it's star wars but it is
star-crossed so
uh check out that one we come back next
week
for more honest trailers commentaries
thanks so much for joining us bye-bye
[Music]
you